>>Male Presenter: All right.
Well, good afternoon everyone.
Thanks for coming out to see Chef Christina
here.
The format today will be--just to give you
the rules of the game --we'll have an awesome
talk by Chef Christina in just a moment.
And it will be followed by some Q&A.
So, if you have a question, please go to the
mic because we are recording this on YouTube.
So, they need to be able to hear you in the
virtual world as well as the real world.
But with that, I'm sure you guys all know
why you're here today.
Chef Christina is here from Momofuku Milk
Bar from New York City.
You know her for her Compost Cookies, her
Crack Pie, her Blueberry Cookies and many,
many other fun and delicious, magically satisfying
treats.
So, I'm sure you guys do not wanna hear any
more of me.
So with that, Chef Christina from Momofuku
Milk Bar.
[applause and cheering]
>>Christina Tosi: Hi everybody.
Can everyone hear me OK?
Awesome.
This is an insane turnout.
[laughing] Thank you to everybody for coming.
I usually--.
We've been doing talks like this.
The book came out on October 25th, so we've
been doing this for about two and a half weeks
on tour.
And it's usually a much smaller group.
And my first question is always like, "OK,
who's ever been to Momofuku?"
Or, "Who owns the Momofuku cookbook?"
Or, "Who's been to Milk Bar?"
And every once in a while, you get a hand
or two raised and it's fun and it's fun to
know that people came just out of curiosity.
But it's pretty amazing [laughing] to see
how many of you came because you know exactly
why you're here.
So, I will spare you with those silly questions.
So, Momofuku Milk Bar.
Momofuku is this tiny little restaurant group
that started in the East Village about seven
years ago by Dave Chang, the chef/owner of
the Momofuku restaurants.
There was Momofuku Noodle Bar, Momofuku Ssäm
Bar, Momofuku Ko, which is like a tasting
menu only restaurant.
You have to get your reservation online only.
Compete for your seats.
Momofuku Milk Bar opened next about three
years ago in November.
And we also have Má Pêche, which is in Midtown
outside of the East Village.
And Dave recently opened a Momofuku restaurant
in Sydney, Australia in the Star City Casino.
And it's going really well.
We now have four little bakeries, or four
little retail Milk Bar locations in New York.
We have our original East Village location.
We have a little location that is part of
Má Pêche in Midtown.
We just opened a spot on the Upper West Side--87th
and Columbus near Central Park.
And we have our kitchen in Williamsburg, Brooklyn
where we also have a little store.
So, hopefully many of you already own the
Momofuku cookbook and you know the history
of the Momofuku restaurants and you know a
little bit about Dave and the mentality and
the attitude and the passion behind what we
do at Momofuku in general.
I started working at Momofuku about six years
ago.
I was, I am still, but I was a home baker
growing up.
I grew up with a bunch of grandmas and aunts
and a mom that really loved baking.
And I also have a very sweet tooth.
So, I loved mixing cookie dough and eating
it more so than baking it.
But I started there with my love for baking
and all things sweet-- cake batters and frostings
and all of those sorts of things.
And I went to college and I studied Applied
Mathematics [laughter] and the Italian language
because I loved doing those things.
I love learning and being stimulated and discovering
these things.
My mom's an accountant, so I think that's
where the mathematics comes into play, but
I ended up graduating from school mostly to
appease my parents.
And I thought to myself that none of those
things would really fit for me as a profession
and that I wanted something more active and
creative and stimulating in this way.
And I feel like you all have figured out a
great way to have that in your lives, but
for me, I thought, "I want to work in a kitchen.
I want to be a pastry chef.
I want to make what my real passion is into
my profession.
So, I moved to New York to, sort of, sight-unseen--.
I had only ever been to New York City for
three hours once when I was a teenager.
And I just felt this draw to New York.
And I thought, "I'm just gonna move to New
York and I'm gonna go to pastry school and
I'm gonna be a pastry chef and that's what
I'm gonna do."
And it just made sense in my head.
So, I just told my parents one day like, "Hey
Mom, this is what I'm gonna do."
And without ever really speaking about it
more, like any further beyond that, I just
had it set in my head.
So, I did it.
And I went to the French Culinary Institute
and I studied pastry arts and I ended up working
in a bunch of fine-dining restaurants in the
city.
Six-day work weeks, sixteen-, eighteen-hour
days, paid almost nothing because I just loved
it so much.
I loved the challenge.
I loved learning.
I loved that I was making a life for myself
and doing what I really loved to do and that
there was no end.
Exhaustion was never really came into mind.
But as I was working in these fine-dining
restaurants and working my way up the ranks
of pastry kitchens and pastry departments,
I got jumbled up because these fine-dining
restaurants usually are very detail-oriented
and they're very precise and they're very--.
I can only ever use the adjective "finicky"
because for me in my head, I see it as finicky.
I see these delicate touilles that top a chocolate
soufflé as finicky.
And six different sauces and picking herbs
and putting them on plate, for my personality,
was like I loved the challenge of it and I
loved learning, but for me, it was far too
finicky for me.
And so, I started to worry that I would never
really actually become a pastry chef and I
would never make it to the top because it
wouldn't really be honest to me and it wouldn't
meet my need and my desire for being creative
and being in a creative profession that had
my voice.
And so, I stepped out.
I ended up stepping out of the kitchen in
New York and trying to figure out what I wanted
to do.
And I met Dave through Wylie Dufresne, who's
the chef and owner at wd~50 in the Lower East
Side.
And it was actually the last kitchen that
I worked in as a pastry cook.
And if you're not familiar with it, it's very
high-technique, very high, forward-thinking
in terms of food and the presentation of food
and pushing boundaries with what you can do
with flavors and techniques and food.
And Wylie ended up introducing me to Dave
to help him with this thing called a HACCP
plan, which is a Hazard Analysis plan for
sous-vide cooking.
If you're not familiar, it's like a large-scale
food saver machine called a Cryovac machine
that creates an oxygen-free environment that
you can cook in.
And the Health Department in New York City
had all of these brand new, very stringent
regulations and Dave needed help.
So, I had taught myself how to write these
plans in working at wd~50 as a pastry cook.
And Wylie was just like, "Can you help my
friend out?"
So, I went and helped Dave out.
And he just offered me a job.
He just said, "OK, you know how to do this
sort of silly, dorky, overextended, HACCP
planning.
You taught yourself so why don't you just
come work for me?"
He had Noodle Bar and Ssäm Bar at the time.
He was just starting to break out in terms
of his presence in food and in the food world
in New York.
And he had a very, very small team of people.
And I just said, "OK.
I'll do it."
Because for me, I really didn't think I was
gonna make it as this pastry chef.
And not because I wouldn't be able to get
there with hard work and determination, but
because I just thought maybe I have it all
wrong and I'm just not creative enough or
I don't have that fine-tuned, precisioned
attention to detail enough to be this fancy
pastry chef.
So, I took the job with Dave because--and
I just said, "Yeah.
I'll do it.
Let's do it.
I'll work for you."
And there was no job role.
It was very un-kitchen related.
It was like, "OK, well you know how to type
on a computer, so how about you do payroll."
[laughter] "And you type faster than me so
how about you type some recipes or the bathroom's
clogged.
Call the plumber.
Figure out how to do it and."
And so, I loved that.
I loved that challenge.
I loved not knowing what I was doing and figuring
it out and I loved knowing that there was
this huge outlet of things for me to learn
how to do and to figure how to do it.
And I loved that sort of uphill battle challenge
that every day was gonna be different and
every day I was gonna be on my feet.
And every day, I was gonna have to find a
creative solution.
And that, for me, was--.
It met enough of that need of what I wanted
to do in a day.
So, I did it.
But the thing was, I'd go to work every day
and do that and then I'd end up coming home
and baking in my kitchen, home late at night
because that was my routine.
It's what I love to do.
It was like, no matter how many hours I spent
at work doing God knows what, all I really
wanted to do was go home and bake.
And it was my peace and my happiness in my
day.
So, I would do it and I would go home.
I'd bake.
I'd bake one or two or three things and I'd
end up just bringing them in the next day
to work, to Dave, and two or three other people
that worked at Momofuku at the time, and feeding
them because I couldn't leave it in my kitchen.
Then I couldn't go home and bake again 'cause
I wouldn't have an empty pan to bake something
into.
And Dave would just gobble it all up.
[laughter] And he would always, after a few
days or a few weeks of it, he would joke that,
"We should put this brownie or this cookie
or whatever it was that I threw together,
on the menu."
Because at the time, Noodle Bar and Ssäm
Bar were very, very masculine, driven with
masculinity in loud, loud music, loud flavors
environment, but there was absolutely no value
placed on dessert.
There wasn't even dessert on the menu, which,
even in New York City, it's strange to have
a restaurant where there's no coffee, there's
no tea, there's no dessert.
You sit down.
The music's playing loud.
You order your food.
You get it.
It comes out warm.
You eat it real fast because it's delicious.
You pay your bill and you leave.
And so, I always thought he was joking about--.
OK, I did, I just threw together these brownies
at home of like whatever was in my cupboard.
It was more just an exercise of peace at home
to bake than it was intentional.
And one day I showed up and halfway through
the day, he was gobbling down whatever I had
eaten and he was just like, "Go.
Go.
Get into the kitchen and make something for
dessert tonight because I don't wanna talk
about it anymore.
I'm over it.
This is clearly what you love to do.
Finish payroll and then go and bake something
[laughter] and we're gonna put it on the menu
tonight because I'm over this.
I don't want to talk about it anymore."
[laughter]
And so, I freaked out.
A lot.
And silently, because there was a show-no-mercy
attitude.
That's kitchen mentality in any city.
That was sort of how I was raised, too, with
the stubbornness.
And I did it.
I made a dessert.
It was a strawberry shortcake with my own
twist on it.
It's in the Momofuku cookbook.
And it was fine.
No one died.
A few people ordered it.
A few people ate it.
It was good.
So, I came back the next day and did my normal
job of whatever it was that came up.
And then I made it again.
And again.
And eventually, I ended up putting desserts
on the menus at the Momofuku Restaurants.
Little by little, I had my fingerprints on
the menus at those restaurants.
And it was one of those "What do you put on
the menu at a restaurant that doesn't serve
dessert?"
There's not really any value placed on dessert,
but these guys clearly love sweets because
when I bring in these platters of things,
they're gone in minutes.
And it's that Momofuku means Lucky Peach in
Japanese, but Dave is a Korean-American chef,
but we use local ingredients, but we use French
technique.
And sometimes, we put a pasta on the menu.
And what in the world do you make for dessert
in those terms?
And it's just like, well, all I know about
working here is that it's faced-paced, the
flavors are big, they're bold.
They're in your face.
Everything always tastes delicious.
It's so delicious that you wanna eat it so
quickly and then get up and leave.
[chuckles] And so, I would do whatever I could
to make a delicious, flavorful, seasonal thing
with a twist and a personality because that
was the only anchor that I had in knowing
Momofuku and in knowing the food of Momofuku
and the personalities of Momofuku.
So, I did that for about a year.
And it was just me and I would just find whatever
space I had on a prep table in one of the
restaurants and just throw as many things
together as I could.
And one day, there was a vacant Laundromat
next to Ssäm Bar on 2nd Avenue and 13th Street.
And they lost their lease.
They were taking all the washers and dryers
out.
And Dave found whatever little corner I was
occupying on a prep table and ran up to me
and said, "The Laundromat is going out of
business.
Somebody's gonna move in and take over the
space and run Momofuku out of--.
They're gonna destroy us.
They're gonna crumble our empire."
Which, of course, is not gonna happen.
[laughter]
But he's has this paranoia about him and this
energy about him because of it.
And it was just like, "We gotta get in there.
Let's open a bakery.
Do you wanna do it?"
Like, let's open this bakery.
And this is like, bringing up a concept that
had never been spoken about between the two
of us.
I'm sure it was clear that I loved cookies
[giggles] and I loved baking cookies.
There was never a cookie on the menu at Ssäm
Bar, at Noodle Bar, at Ko, because that just
wasn't the vibe of those restaurants.
And I was just like, "Sure.
Yeah, sure, I'll do it."
In my head, like every little girl dreams
about having a bakery.
[laughter]
So, "Sure, I'll do it."
And I was like, "I'm serious.
Do you wanna do it?
If you say yes, we have to do it right now."
And it was like, "Yeah, OK.
I said yes.
Let's do it."
[laughter]
And so, we just did it.
And it was like one of those phone calls home
to my mom, or was similar to, "Hey, so Mom.
I'm gonna move to New York City and go pastry
school and become a pastry chef and I'm gonna
get on a train tomorrow."
And it was the same sort of thing where it
was like, "Hey Mom, I'm gonna open this bakery
and it's gonna open in like a month and I'll
tell you when that is" sort of thing.
And then you just do it.
And it's being a person of your word and suppressing
all of the fear and doubt and all of those
things in your head and just pushing through.
And I like to say we opened the bakery overnight,
though it took a little while to renovate
this laundromat into a bakery.
But it ended up being this bakery that, in
my head, it makes sense to the way Momofuku
and the Momofuku restaurants and the menus
are in terms of food and flavors and curiosities.
But we ended up opening this bakery.
And I like to describe it as this quirky bakery
with an American baked goods sensibility,
but with a little bit of a twist, or with
a little more personality, because instead
of chocolate chip cookies, we sell cornflake
chocolate chip marshmallow cookies.
Or, instead of chocolate chip cookies, we
sell compost cookies that have chocolate chips
in them, but they also have butterscotch chips
and pretzels and potato chips and coffee grounds
and stuff like that.
And making the menu was just making a bunch
of stuff that I knew I loved baking at home
or making this cookie dough and then throwing
whatever I had in my cupboard into this cookie
dough.
And it made sense in my head.
And I was too busy to worry about it not making
sense in anyone else's head.
And I sort of got tricked into being this
pastry chef that I didn't know that I was,
or that I could be, and I ended up making
this menu that I thought, "I'm just gonna
make what makes sense in my head and what's
honest to what I love to bake and what I know
how to bake and what I know how to bake for
somebody or for a family meal or what have
you."
And it's honest and it feels right and then
I'm not gonna worry about anything else.
And so, everything that we sell I think makes
sense in our head, though most people ask
how we come up with it or how it came to be.
And so, we brought a lot of stuff for you
guys to taste so that you could understand
our food beyond--.
Strip it down for you beyond just a cookie.
So for me, making this menu for a bakery was
like, "OK, I've been training to be a pastry
chef for many years.
What do pastry chefs, where do you start?
Do you start with flavor?
Do you start with texture?
Do you start with technique?"
And for me, I would strip it down to my favorite
things that I loved making as a pastry cook
in other people's pastry kitchens.
And I'm a real creature of texture.
I love crunch.
Even if it's not crunch as a texture, it's
silky smooth or it's sandy or it's crumby
or what have you.
And so, we started playing around with these
crumbs and crunches, which makes sense in
my head, but there are these pops of color
and flavor and texture.
The cook book is laid out with these basic
techniques and ingredients that we love to
use in our kitchen when we start to bake,
when we start to develop our menu and a new
recipe.
One of the things that we love making is a
crunch and we brought cornflake crunch today.
And it's made with Corn Flakes, so that always
makes people smile.
And it's a flavor that most people know and
can relate to.
And we toss it with some sugar and some salt
and some melted butter and some milk powder.
And we just spread it out on a sheet pan and
toast it off in the oven so you get an idealized
version of Corn Flakes or maybe an idealized
version of Frosted Flakes, or something like
that.
In most pastry kitchens you'll use something
like this that has this flavor and texture
and broken down organic nature and you'll
use it to just put on the bottom of a plate
to hold a scoop of ice cream so it doesn't
slide around on the plate when it goes to
the table.
But for me, I thought, "Well, I wanna make
this crunch or this crumb, and what else can
I do with it?"
And so, we would just play around with flavors
until we got a lot of fun, different crunches.
We make one with Ritz Crackers.
We make one with Fruity Pebbles.
We make one with pretzels.
It's basically anything that already has a
flavor and a texture that you just crumble
up with your hands, butter, sugar, salt, maybe
some milk powder.
You bake it off.
And then, we'll take these little things,
these little snacky items and we'll see how
many places we can put them--on restaurant
menus and on our bakery menu.
And we make a Corn Flake, chocolate chip,
marshmallow cookie.
And it's a chocolate chip cookie, but we fold
this Corn Flake crunch into it and we put
these mini marshmallows in it.
And all of a sudden, we have this amped up
version of a chocolate chip cookie.
And we'll take this Corn Flake crunch and
we'll use it as an ice cream topping.
Or, we'll take it and we'll crunch it down
a little bit more and we'll press it into
a pie tin and use it as a pie crust instead
of your average pie crust because why not?
And I don't wanna make a pie crust.
I have this great snacky thing.
I mean, I personally will just--.
We have little cups to pass around for you
guys to taste.
But it's good to just throw back or make it
into a trail mix or make it into a granola.
And instead of starting off with something
like a pie crust or instead of starting off
with just looking at flour, sugar, and butter
as a dough, how can I start from a more creative
standpoint?
And then that's my staple ingredient that
I use and I see how far I can push it.
You can layer it in a cake for flavor and
texture and a visual appeal.
And you can play with the flavor of Corn Flakes.
You can play with the flavor of cereal.
And you can substitute it in and out.
And so, we start with these--.
Instead of starting with just butter and sugar,
instead of starting with just a cake recipe,
we'll start with these crumbs and these crunches
because you're starting from like a platform
of something a little bit more creative or
a little different.
Or, you're starting with something that doesn't
already exist in everybody else's kitchen.
We make this thing called a Milk Crumb.
And it's like a sandy burst of flavor.
And in a lot of pastry kitchens, in savory
kitchens, they make them.
Sometimes they call them crumbs.
Sometimes they call them sand.
It was a very 90s thing with the Adria Brothers.
And even at wd~50, we would make red onion
sand and soil.
We would make coffee soil.
And it's just this sandy burst of flavor.
But when I started menu developing for Milk
Bar, I thought, "I love this technique."
I would stand in the kitchen when no one was
looking and just eat these crumbs as my snack.
[laughter]
And I would pour milk over them and eat them
as cereal.
And so I thought, "Well I'm gonna take that
technique and see what I can with it in terms
of flavor that pushes it beyond what I already
know."
And again, we would use this and we would
drape it over a plate of foie gras at wd~50
for flavor and for texture.
We'd sprinkle a little down on a plate and
put a scoop of ice cream or a quenelle of
sorbet on it.
But for me, I thought, "Well, what else can
we do with this?"
And it's milk powder.
It's milk powder.
I don't know if anyone's mom or dad ever used
milk powder and hydrated it with water and
made them drink milk as a kid.
I did.
[laughs] And it was gross back then, but I
thought, "Let's use this milk powder."
Which is a staple in any pastry chef's kitchen
because you typically put it in ice cream
to give it more body and flavor.
"Let's make an idealized version of what milk
should taste like."
Like, in my head, milk should be sweet and
milky and a little savory, but to have this
balance that regular milk doesn't really have.
My mom used to make me drink skim milk as
a kid and I hated it.
So, I want to take what I think milk should
taste like and then make that into a crumb.
So, it's flour.
It's butter.
It's sugar.
It's milk powder as the dried flavored ingredient
that goes into it.
And we put a little white chocolate in here.
And then we take this crumb and we fold it
into a cookie dough and we have a cookie called
the Blueberry Cream cookie.
I think about milk crumbs and I go, "OK.
It's milky.
It's creamy."
So then I think about peaches and cream.
And then I think about blueberries and cream.
And then I think about blueberry muffin.
And then I think about the best part of a
blueberry muffin, which is the tippy top of
the muffin where it's a little fudgy and a
little crunchy.
And we make it into a cookie.
So, we take these milk crumbs and we fold
them into a cookie dough with dried blueberries.
We'll also take it and we'll use it in a plated
dessert for one of the restaurants and we'll
make a peach sorbet because peaches and cream
makes sense to everybody.
And then we take some graham crackers and
we'll blend them down into a puree that we
like to call a ganache 'cause it represents
a little bit more texture and body in the
world of cooking and pastry chef-dom.
And all of a sudden, you have milk crumbs
and peaches for a peaches and cream element.
And then you have this peach sorbet and this
graham cracker ganache and it gives you this
peach cobbler effect.
And all of a sudden we're just using the same
crumb we use in so many different things,
but we're figuring out how many different
places we can re-purpose it and how creative
we can get with it.
We layer it in a pistachio cake that has layers
of pistachio cake and lemon curd and these
milk crumbs and pistachio frosting.
And it gives a nuttiness and a floralness
and this sweet, milkiness that brings out
both and enhances it.
It gives it texture and it gives it a visual
pop.
And it makes sense and it's fun and it tastes
good.
And all of a sudden, we've created five or
six desserts out of two things that we really
just like snacking on in our kitchen.
[giggles] We also have a birthday crumb that's
sort of like--.
Did anybody's mom or dad or sister or aunt
or uncle ever make them a boxed Funfetti cake
for your birthday?
[chuckles]
For me, that's the best birthday cake ever.
And we thought, "OK, we're gonna be this quirky
bakery with baked goods.
It's personal to us.
We want it to have personality and we want
it to--.
All baked goods should feel like home and
should be made with love."
And for me, it's like that funny dichotomy
of well, this box cake mix that you just add
eggs and oil to, it tastes like home because
that's what you make for your kid when you're
trying to raise a family and you wanna make
a birthday cake.
So, we took our love for that Funfetti box
cake mix and we totally deconstructed it to,
"So many people make this box cake mix from
a box.
How about if we figure out how to make it
from scratch?"
Because those flavors are the flavors of home
and the flavors that you relate to and that
you remember and that send this signal or
this eye--.
They make your eyes get wider.
And how do we make that flavor from scratch?"
And so, we would take the back of a box of--.
We take the Funfetti cake mix home and we
look at the back of the box and just start
deconstructing.
Like, how are we gonna recreate these flavors
in our kitchen?
And we figured out how to remake the cake
from scratch.
We figured out how to make frosting that tastes
just like it's that shelf-stable canned frosting
[laughter] that you eat through your childhood
and through college.
And we ended up making these crumbs out of
it as well.
And it's the same ingredients that are in
a cake, but instead of making it into a cake
with butter and eggs and oil, we make it into
a little crumb with just a little bit of melted
butter.
And we'll take it and we'll fold it into a
cookie to make a confetti cookie.
And we'll layer it into that birthday cake
that we make from scratch for more texture
and more flavor.
And we go.
That's how we go from there.
We start with these crumbs or these crunches.
We make this milk called Cereal Milk and it's
meant to taste like what's left in your bowl
after you eat all the cereal out of it, which
is a flavor that everybody knows whether it's
made with Lucky Charms or made with Capn Crunch
or made with Golden Grahams.
Everybody knows that flavor of milk.
Like, everyone's done that before and so,
that's a recipe that we'll start with in our
kitchen and we'll see how many places we can
put it.
We make it into drinking milk.
We make it into ice cream.
We set it with a little bit of gelatin and
we make into a panna cotta.
And all of a sudden, we have one simple approach
and one simple flavor and we have three or
four new menu items.
We'll take this Corn Flake crunch and press
it into a crust and then fill it with Cereal
Milk ice cream because it just makes sense.
And we're just using things that are already
in our kitchen.
We're using these recipes that are already
So when we went to write the cook book and
tell the story of Milk Bar and how it came
to be and the attitude and the mentality behind
it and the sense of humor behind it, we broke
it down based on these recipes which we jokingly
refer to as "mother recipes."
And we relate it back to French cooking.
And in French cooking you have mother sauces
and it's this well-known principle that if
you know how to make these mother sauces,
if you can master these mother sauces in French
cooking, they gateway towards mastering French
cooking as a whole is yours.
And these mother sauces are the gateway to
mastering everything else in French cooking.
And so, we approach Milk Bar with the same
mentality, where it's like, if you know--.
There's Cereal Milk.
If you know how to make Cereal Milk, you have
this gateway into what we do at Milk Bar.
Once you get the Corn Flake Crunch down or
the Milk Crumb down, you have this world of
desserts opened up to you.
And that's how we do it in our kitchen.
We get creative by starting with really creative,
staple, pantry ingredients.
We make thing called Liquid Cheesecake because
if I were gonna be a fancy pastry chef, I
might make blue cheese cheesecake and serve
it with figs or poached pears or something
like that.
But I'm not.
[laughter] I want under baked cheesecake because
that's the best part of cheesecake for me.
It's that little ring in the center when somebody
doesn't bake it all the way and I just wanna
spoon that out.
So, if I'm gonna be a pastry chef, I know
that cheesecake is a staple thing to pastry
chefs, but my cheesecake's gonna be liquid
cheesecake because that's the best part of
cheesecake for me.
And I'm not afraid to say it.
And it might be a little low brow, but it
gets a laugh and you get it because that's
like everyone's dirty little secret.
[chuckles] And that's what we have in our
kitchen and that's what we use as our jumping-off
point.
And that's how the cookbook is laid out.
It's like, we make this liquid cheesecake.
We layer it on this bread dough and make a
cinnamon bun pie because if you think about
cinnamon buns, it's bread dough and it's cinnamon
and sugar and light brown sugar.
And then you roll it up and then you lather
it in cream cheese frosting.
So, I'm gonna take this liquid cheesecake
I have and I'm gonna use it to get towards
this idea of a cinnamon bun in a different
shape and a different vehicle.
But the flavors are there and they make sense
and everyone knows the flavor of a cinnamon
bun.
But we make it into a pie with liquid cheesecake.
[giggles] And I think that personality and
that sort of honesty about baking and baked
goods and pastries is very much the path that
we take when we made Milk Bar at the very
beginning and when we're coming up with new
menu items every day.
And that is really important to us.
And I think the underlying thing for us is
I started making these desserts at this restaurant
where everything's loud and masculine and
in your face.
And dessert didn't exist before.
And in order for it to be worth my time, it's
not like I want dessert to be the shining
star, but damnit, I came to work today and
I worked really hard and I want everything
that we serve as a dessert to stand out.
But at a tasting-menu only restaurant when
you're already getting stuffed with twelve
courses and the last two courses are dessert,
it's like, how do you make your dessert memorable
and how do you make it poignant?
And how do you make it stand out?
Or, how do you make people want to remember
their 13th and their 14th course when they've
been sitting down and eating for two hours
already?
And I think that's always the underlying motivation,
the underlying, "check" this is it, we're
done.
We're done recipe testing.
This is making it to the menu and well, it
still needs some work.
And some of our recipes are immediately--.
[snaps fingers] They hit you.
You have it.
You know you've got it.
And other ones are like, we're constantly
tasting and testing because it has to pass
that taste test where, even in our kitchen
full of cookie dough and cake batter, you
just want to keep going back and eating and
munching and almost making yourself sick because
it's got to hit home like that.
And it doesn't have to be a childhood memory
and it doesn't have to be a breakfast memory,
but those are things that help strike a chord
with people.
It makes your eyes open.
It makes you wanna come back for more.
It makes you want to beg your friend before
they get on their flight to go the bakery
and pick up a bunch of cookies because somehow
you have a relationship with it.
And that's what baked goods are.
That's what they are for me.
I have a relationship with oatmeal raisin
cookies because my grandma used to make them
for me all the time when I was a kid.
And I don't want anybody else's oatmeal raisin
cookie.
But if there's something about a dessert that
taps in to that cinnamony, sugary, oatmealy,
raisony flavors on any level,
I'm sold.
I will never forget it because that's how
I was raised with baked goods.
And that's for me, what feels like home and
what impresses me the most and those are the
home run dishes and those are the things I
remember.
And it's the same thing with savory food,
but we're in the dessert world and so we're
constantly looking at it as a competition
on a level where it's like, how do we tap
into that as well?
And it has to be the most delicious thing
that anyone's ever ate.
Otherwise, it doesn't make it onto the menu
because that takes extra time and it takes
extra effort, but that's how you make a bakery
like this and a restaurant group like Momofuku
and a dessert program like we have.
And that is the essence of what we do at Momofuku
and what we do at Milk Bar and what you get
in the cook book beyond just the recipes of--.
OK, you get the Compost Cookie recipe.
I promise.
But you get this personality and this approach
and this realness about it where you understand
where it comes from.
And you're one of us.
I mean, we let you into our kitchen and our
mentality and our point of view.
We tell bad jokes in the book.
[giggles] And we break it all down.
So, that's what you're taking home.
But I wanna see what kind of questions you
guys have because that's personally--.
I get a little itchy when it's time to talk,
but my favorite part is answering questions
because the dialogue of it I think is really
important.
So, who has questions?
Come on.
Yes.
>>FEMALE #1: Hi, my name is Julie.
I love Milk Bar.
I went there like, three years ago.
>>Christina Tosi: Oh, at the very beginning.
>>FEMALE #1: I got engaged near there with
my husband and his brother.
So, I'm really connected to the food and everything.
So, when I went back recently, your cookies
changed a little bit.
So, they were packaged.
They tasted different.
The shapes were different.
So I wanted to hear you speak a little bit
about how growing and expanding has changed
your recipe and if you think it's still--.
I mean, it's still really delicious, but it's
different.
So we had a different experience going back
recently than we did three years ago.
>>Christina Tosi: Yeah.
So, we opened Milk Bar in the East Village
three years ago.
And we did all of our baking on site.
And it was actually just me and two other
people that opened the bakery and we worked
day and night.
We had no clue what we were doing.
We just knew that we had a delicious product
that we stood behind.
And we had very little resources and very
little equipment.
And we ended up working from 6AM until two
or three o'clock in the morning for days and
days and days and months.
And it ended up being such a huge--.
We baked, we mixed everything on site.
We baked everything on site.
We sold everything ourselves.
And it ended up being this crazy success,
line out the door, from open till close, from
8AM till midnight we would have a line out
the door.
And we would kill ourselves just--.
The Compost Cookie.
This is everyone's favorite.
We would end up mixing this dough so many
times over the course of the day, and scooping
it and trying to find room in our small refrigerators
to find a place to chill it before we baked
it.
And then we would scoop them into paper bags
on the fly while they were still kind of warm
in hopes that people were gonna eat them right
away.
And if they didn't, they were gonna grease
their bags and break down because we were
so overwhelmed with it.
And I think that's what made it such a success
at first because it felt so personal and human.
And it's still very personal to us, but the
thing that people forget sometimes with bakeries,
we've had a crash course on not only how to
open a bakery, but how to be a business person
on this really weird level that was completely
unslated is that you can sell a lot of cookies
to pay your rent in New York City, to pay
hardworking people a wage that is not poverty,
where they're not living with six people in
bunk beds with bed bugs.
In order to pay people that believe in what
you do and what they do an honest wage, you
have to sell a lot of cookies.
And we were put in this space because we thought
we would just be this cute little bakery that
sold breads and flavored butters and cookies.
And the demand of the business and the cookie
sales was so huge that we were all of a sudden
in this small space with this dedicated team
that was getting paid next to nothing and
working day in and day out.
And it was like, we're never gonna be able
to sustain this.
We're gonna kill ourselves trying to make
enough cakes and layer them all on this 250
or 300 square foot kitchen space.
And we got to the point that we were taking
refrigerators and illegally putting them in
portions of where our customers would stand
in line and wait or try and eat and lock them.
And illegally do it through the Health Department
because it was like, you're gonna get mad
if I don't have a Compost Cookie.
And I'm gonna get mad if I don't have a Compost
Cookie for you, but I don't know how else
to do it.
And it got to the point that we were shipping
cookies because people want to have cookies
on the West Coast if they can't make it to
visit us.
And we got to the point where we just started
taking tables out of the bakery for patrons
and we would just start stacking boxes of
tins and stuff like that.
We had no shipping area, so we would just
be like, "You can't have this table.
You cannot eat Crack Pie at this table because
I'm gonna put an ugly tablecloth on it and
I'm gonna pack stuff and send it up."
And all of a sudden, we were affronted with
what do we do?
And what's important?
And what's our vision?
And we ended up being like, "We need a bigger
boat.
If we're gonna do this, we need a bigger boat."
And we're getting to the point that we're
almost selling enough cookies that we can
start to pay people a wage that's just somewhere
near honest.
It's not even close to it, but we're to the
point where we can provide health insurance
for our employees, which is unheard of in
the restaurant industry, especially in New
York.
And we have to keep going because we're almost
to the point where we can do it all.
We can have it all and we can have lives and
we can do what we love.
And we ended up getting a bigger kitchen in
Williamsburg.
And believe it or not, our cookie recipes
haven't changed at all.
We use the exact same ingredients, but the
things that have changed are we make them
off site.
And we used to scoop every single cookie by
hand, but all of a sudden, we were affronted
with, "Nobody scoops fast enough for me."
The test of our kitchen used to be like, "OK,
you can get hired if you can scoop cookies
almost as fast as me because I'm gonna love
it more than anyone and I'm gonna be faster
than anyone, so I'm gonna scoop scoop scoop."
And then all of a sudden, it was like, "We're
gonna need to hire 12 people just to scoop
enough cookies."
And so, we had to be smart about our strategy
in how we do it.
We package everything, honestly because in
New York City, you are not allowed to bake
product off site and send it to another location--.
You're not allowed to bake something on site
and send it to another location to sell retail
unless it's packaged and it's labeled with
every ingredient and every potential allergy.
And all of a sudden, it's like we love what
we do on the same level, but we have to figure
out a way to make a concession here or there
so that we can, so everyone can know what
a Compost Cookie is.
And you don't get as big of a bit of a pretzel
in it now, but if we write a cook book, then
people can still make it at home and it's
still special to us even though it's not.
We're not.
We used to be in this 250 square foot space
with this small group of five or six people
that would just kill each other, like lifting
things up and over and under.
And now, we're in this huge kitchen and it's
like, how do we maintain our sense of family
and our passion for it and our love for it?
And we still do it every day.
And we sometimes joke that we do not miss
that space at all because it was so hard.
But we miss it so much because we know exactly
what the places that we had to make the concessions
and that we had to say, "You wanna know what?
I am not gonna be here every day to scoop
cookies and to be the only one to scoop cookies."
If I could, I would.
But I can't.
And we still stand behind what we do.
>>FEMALE #1: Well, thank you for scooping
the cookie the day that I was there.
>>MALE #1: Hey, Christina.
Thanks so much for coming.
Your passion is so obvious to all of us.
You've already actually started talking about
this, but I remember I went to the Noodle
Bar the first time and now, every time I hear
about you guys, you have an uptown location
and there's a bakery.
You're going to Sydney.
And you were already going along those lines,
but how do you maintain this kind of Momofuku
sense, like in the passion and all that.
'Cause you guys have grown.
'Cause you guys seem like interminable, right?
It's like every time--.
There's nothing gonna stop you guys, right?
[laughter]
I mean, the passion is so obvious and the
innovativeness is so cool.
How do you maintain that?
What is it that keeps you guys special?
>>Christina Tosi: It's really hard.
I mean, I think that having a personality
and maintaining your love for it is so important
and it's one of those things that no one talks
about.
And I want my cookie or I want my bowl of
Ramen and I want it now.
And the attitude and the personality behind
it is what makes it and what drives it and
what keeps it going.
And it's something that we probably spend
hours talking about in our kitchen.
In Milk Bar, we spent hours talking about
each one of our cooks and each one of our
employees and where they're at and how can
we get everyone to contribute and know that
they're part of this family.
And we'll do everything from like, "OK, we're
recipe testing or we're menu developing for
the next Momofuku Noodle Bar soft serve flavors.
Who has an idea?
Fall is coming up.
I don't care if you're a dishwasher.
I don't care if you are the one that puts
the stickers on the backs of the bags of cookies.
You're here for a reason and you have and
you know Momofuku and you know Milk Bar at
a level.
And I'm like, what's next?
You tell me.
How are we gonna do this together and how
are we gonna drive it together?"
And I think creating that sense of family
and care and being like, if I have to put
a cookie in a bag with a label on it to make
sure that you're here and you can make a living
and you can be a part of it, then that's what
we're gonna do.
How are we gonna do this?
And so, I think it's about hiring good people
and banding together and figuring out a way
to continue to perpetuate the message and
the passion.
And the rest of it comes organically.
I mean, the rest of it like, gut checking
and it's like, "I don't know if I wanna open
a Milk Bar in Australia."
It would be awesome to live in Australia,
but is that the consensus?
For Milk Bar, it's like we have this team
and we're a team and if we move to Australia,
that means part of our team and our family's
gonna move away and is that what we wanna
do?
Can we sustain it?
Can we maintain it?
And that's the question that happens every
time we open a new Momofuku, whether it's
a savory restaurant or it's a Milk Bar.
It’s like, why are we doing it?
How are we doing it?
Is this what we wanna do?
And it becomes this very cerebral thing where
you think like, "You're cooks.
You're chefs.
You come up with new menu things and you put
them on the menu and they're great."
And it ends up being this much more business
savvy, cerebral family meeting time sort of
thing about it.
And I think that's the part of having a restaurant
group and running restaurants and running
a bakery that people forget and miss, but
it actually is a huge portion of our day and
our week.
And figuring out, how do you do it?
You have to constantly change.
You have to constantly learn.
You have to eat out.
You have to take in.
You have to do all those things.
And how do you keep with it?
And how do you keep fresh?
And how do you keep a personality?
And how do you keep your stuff trendy, but
not trendy?
You know what I mean?
Trendy, but not trendy.
How do you stand on your own island and do
it with a group of people?
And I don't know what the answer is.
All I can tell you is that it's something
that we spend a huge amount of time on, figuring
out and talking about.
And every--.
We change.
We change every, every, every, every single
day.
Like, "OK, we think this was a great idea.
Let's do it today."
And then three days later, it's like, "That's
a terrible idea.
Let's not do it at all."
Or, "I'm gonna paint the floor over here 'cause
it's gonna make everyone feel great about
working this station."
And we just constantly change and that's how
we stay.
We're never stagnant.
We constantly--.
Whether it's something big or something small,
or something that goes on the menu or how
we tray up cookies before they get baked off
in the oven or whatever it is, and we just
constantly stay in over our head, always.
[laughs]
>>MALE #1: Cool.
You haven't stumbled yet.
I didn't hear anything I didn't like.
So, thanks.
>>Christina Tosi: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #2: I just had a quick question about
what would be the one thing that you could
bake literally all day and not get tired of?
>>Christina Tosi: That's a great question.
I mean, for me, I feel like the answer is
always cookie dough [giggles] because mixing
it, eating it, baking it.
Honestly, we were doing a book talk yesterday
night at Omnivore and someone was like, "I
currently work in a bakery, but I think I
wanna work in a restaurant and don't you miss
like working service and plating desserts?"
And I was like, "No, I don't miss it at all."
And the reason that I knew I wanted a bakery
and love what I do is because I could do any
of those things all day every day.
If I had to stand there and put cookies in
a bag all day every day, I would happily do
it and it would be my favorite activity.
'Cause it would mean that somebody's, that
many people are eating the blueberry and cream
cookie.
And that for me is like, I'll do whatever
it takes and it never gets old.
>>FEMALE #2: Thank you.
And will you be making them for the holidays
there?
>>Christina Tosi: Making the blueberry and
cream cookies for the holidays?
For the holidays, we have planned to take
the corn flake chocolate chip marshmallow
cookie and crush up candy canes and peppermints
and fold them in.
The recipe is also in the cook book.
It's one of our favorite things to do over
the holidays.
One, because no one wants to say good bye
to any of the cookies out here.
So, you have to make a holiday cookie within
the realm of the current offerings because
if you take the Compost Cookie away or the
Corn Cookie away, I'll tell you what.
There's gonna be hell to pay.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE #2: Thank you.
>>FEMALE #3: Hey Christina.
Thank you so much for coming today on behalf
of everyone at Google.
I think that's it for questions.
I know a lot of people still wanna get their
books and they're available back there.
And I know she also brought a lot of treats.
>>Christina Tosi: Yeah.
We brought a ton of cookies and crumbs and
crunches.
So, come up.
[applause]